meagan Markel and prince harry want your
help the royal duo took to Instagram on
Wednesday asking fans who they should
feature next writing we want to know who
your force for changes since announcing
the social media campaign in April Megan
and Harry have followed different
accounts each month based on a new theme
in May they featured Mental Health
Organization's June was focused on pride
and July was all about environmental
causes remember that adorable video of
Harry dancing with famed primatologist
Jane Goodall The Post continues asking
followers to nominate someone you look
up to the organization doing amazing
work that we should all be following an
account that inspires you to be and do
better or that simply makes you feel
good or the handle that brims with
optimism for a brighter tomorrow the
Sussex duo plan to follow 15 of the
suggested accounts on August 5th the day
after Megan's 38th birthday my foster
change is scratches invoke my force for
change is is here on the shoe it's Yara
Shahidi for me I think Chimamanda is
incredibly inspiring
of course Meghan just revealed her own
15 forces for change in the September
issue of British Vogue which she guest
edited alongside editor-in-chief Edward
and in fall the issue hits newsstands on
August 2nd I feel extremely privileged
to work with Edward and the Dutchess of
Sussex I love their complicity to make
this secret project such an example of
collaboration together and inclusiveness
[Music]